last year the James Webb Space Telescope
began sending back incredible
unprecedented images of the universe
with its back to our sun shielding
itself from the saturating light of our
star it turned its massive golden
mirrors to the universe
focusing the light it gathered onto
cryogenically cool sensors peering back
to the cold distant red-shifted light
emitted 13.5 billion years ago in the
early stages of our universe an
incredible human achievement but what if
we created a massive radio Space
Telescope we could peer even further
back in time detecting signals emitted
from hydrogen atoms in our primordial
Universe light that even the James Webb
Space Telescope can't detect
however radio telescopes are massive
building a collecting area this large is
a challenge even on Earth one of our
largest radio telescopes the Arecibo
telescope collapsed in 2020 after 57
years of service as a result of two
supporting cables snapping this
telescope used a natural sinkhole to
shape and support the spherical dish
radar waves from this distant past are
blocked by our atmosphere but what if we
could build something like this in space
using naturally formed craters in the
same way the Arecibo used its sinkhole
that is precisely the plan proposed by
NASA scientists a radio telescope on The
Far Side of the Moon using one of the
many craters Pock marking its surface it
would be the largest Space Telescope
ever constructed and using clever
engineering it could be vastly cheaper
than the James Webb Telescope this is
its story
[Music]
the basic concept of a massive radio
telescope is not new the Arecibo
observatory in Puerto Rico was a huge
300 meter diameter dish but this Moon
telescope would be even bigger with a
1.3 kilometer wide crater the engineers
of this project will be able to suspend
a dish with a diameter 50 meters greater
than the Arecibo Observatory this
proposal is part of a program at Nasa
where researchers are encouraged to
think about futuristic technologies that
could be plausible within the next 10 to
20 years
so how plausible is this building
structures on the moon is not easy the
core idea behind this telescope is to
use a crater on the moon as a bowl
removing the need for heavy support
structures and constructing the dish
from wire meshes that naturally sag
under the moon's gravity to form a
reflective dish
the use of the mesh wire drastically
reduces the weight of the system while
still allowing radio waves to bounce off
it as long as the gaps in the mesh are
shorter than the incoming Signal's
wavelength the wave will bounce off just
like the holes in the screen mesh of
your microwave allow visible light to
pass through but reflect the longer
wavelengths of the microwaves themselves
in order for this to work we need to
find the perfect crater and scientists
have been scouring over data obtained
from the lunar reconnaissance Orbiter
since 2009 first it needs to be on The
Far Side of the Moon the Moon is tidally
locked to the Earth and thus The Far
Side is always facing away from Earth
and so it Shields it from the radio
Noise We emit the further away the
crater is from the near Side of the Moon
the better to fit the 350 meter wide
dish the crater needs to be five
kilometers in circumference and 175
meters deep it also needs to be a smooth
as possible lacking any large Boulders
or mounts the rim must also be as level
as possible to allow for easy anchoring
of the hanging wires finally we want to
point away from the center of the Milky
Way galaxy our galaxy to observe the
radio waves emitted from the early
Universe we want to point our telescope
to the quieter parts of the universe but
we can't point a crater we have to rely
on the moon's natural motion to sweep a
section of the sky this Trace sweep
changes depending on the north-south
location of the crater by choosing a
crater further north between 10 and 20
degrees the telescope can avoid the
noise of the Milky Way galaxy these
criteria narrow down the options from 82
000 craters on The Far Side of the Moon
to just 300. from those 300 50 were
chosen for more careful consideration
this crater here almost 10 degrees north
was the chosen one construction on the
moon is perhaps the largest challenge
facing this project the telescope is
going to focus on capturing information
from the electromagnetic spectrum
between 4.7 megahertz and 47 megahertz
this corresponds to a wavelength between
6.4 and 64 meters this leads us to one
of the first engineering design
constraints the dish needs to reflect
and focus these waves on Earth mass is
not a huge constraint for a stationary
structure however we will need to ship
these materials from Earth at a huge
expense per kilogram so we want to
minimize waste where possible we can
form a support structure with
lightweight carbon fiber cables this
material also helps with maintaining the
structured shape as the temperatures on
the moon swings widely from -170 degrees
Celsius to 120 degrees Celsius over its
night and daytime Cycles a temperature
swing that would cause aluminum to
expand and contract warping the shape
these carbon fiber wires will then be
anchored on the crater sides with the
natural sag in The Wire forming the
support structure however hanging wires
will naturally create a cantenary shape
which is not suitable as a concave
mirror we need to create a shape capable
of focusing the reflected
electromagnetic waves to a point inside
the crater where we can hang a receiver
to get a better focused beam the shape
must be closer to a half circle but how
can we achieve that with a wire with
just two anchor points this is where
things get interesting wires have no
compressive strength and must hang in
pure tension hang a wire from a single
point and it will hang straight down
hang it from two points and it will sag
downwards until once again the entire
string is in tension but if we put more
waste it will sag with the deeper
parabolic Arch to allow it to remain in
tension we can take advantage of this by
hanging weight strategically along its
lent to alter its shape this can be done
by tailoring the wire shape along its
length or by coating the wire in
materials of different densities along
its land but anchoring the tethers to
the rim is easier said than done
especially if we're going to be
constructing it without the help of
astronauts
thankfully the moon's weaker gravity
makes things easier the moon's gravity
is about 16 diverts
supporting a 200 kilogram telescope on
the moon is equivalent to holding just
about 320 kilograms on Earth the
question is how do we deploy them one
plan involves using dual axle robots
currently being developed by JPL to
manually tow the wires into place
another plan is to form the anchoring
wire shape above the crater before
landing either by the Lander firing
anchors before landing or through
multiple Landers landing at their anchor
sites however the cheapest option
involves a single lunar lander that will
land in the center of the crater and
fire the anchors above the Crater Rim
these anchors are similar to both
anchors and upon tensioning will dig
into the lunar regolith however the
lunar regolith is razor sharp and great
caution needs to be taken to minimize
friction between the tethers and the
ground depending on projectiles also
requires extensive testing and
validation to ensure their reliability
and prevent event any potential failures
a difficult thing to simulate which is
highly dependent on the terrain of the
site on the other hand relying only on
projectiles greatly decreases cost and
complexity with an estimated total cost
of 2.4 billion dollars it's estimated
that deploying the wires with Rovers
would cost 4.5 billion for comparison
the James Webb Telescope costs 10
billion dollars
once deployed these anchors are the
skeleton upon which the rest of the
structure is built the antenna receiver
is raised to the focal point of the
structure first if deployed by
individual robotic anchor points the
tensioning of these wires could be done
from the anchor points but this again
would pull the wires along extremely
abrasive lunar regolith ideally a robot
pulley system can climb the existing
anchoring wires and deploy these
structures without causing any more
friction on the Crater Rim next is the
reflector mesh this mesh will be made
from an ultralight reflective material
like gold-plated molybdenum to deploy
the reflector guide wires are pulled to
the top of the anchoring wires which in
turn will unfurl the wire mesh carefully
folded the board inspired by origami
this concept has been modeled in
multiple space missions from solar
arrays to inflatable heat shields with
good reason origami with its intricate
folds allows Engineers to hack large
structures into extremely tight spaces
the perfect solution for packing a 350
meter wide radar dish into a space
confined lunar lander once deployed the
radio telescope can begin sending data
back to Earth but this telescope won't
be giving us pretty images like the
James Webb Telescope it will instead
give us data on how hydrogen is
distributed in the universe but how is
that useful it will give us a new
understanding of how the universe formed
right now the main hypothesis is that
hydrogen distribution should be uniform
over space and time but that Assumption
of uniformity was also made of a cosmic
background radiation which turned out to
be false
assumptions like this need to be tested
and not just given as a fact and this
telescope will be able to detect these
hydrogens but how in the early Universe
before Stars began to form there was no
lights but there were hydrogen atoms a
lot of hydrogen atoms cold Interstellar
hydrogens are at their lowest possible
energy level and radiate nothing however
on occasion these atoms can become
excited to a higher energy State through
collisions with other atomic particles
at some point through natural Decay or
through a secondary Collision this
energy needs to be radiated out again
and the energy is released with a photon
in a very specific wavelength 21
centimeters long giving the phenomenon
its name the 21 centimeter line by
listening for radio waves at this
particular frequency we can quantify
hydrogen formation Across the Universe
but the goal is more than just
collecting signals from one point in
time the goal would be to track these
formations over time we can do this
because of red shifting as the universe
expands it stretches the frequencies to
lower and lower or frequencies we can
identify the age of the signal by how
much the signal has shifted into longer
wavelengths this data is crucial for
refining our models regarding the
conditions that led to the formation of
stars and providing insights into How
the Universe gradually cooled following
the Big Bang of course the telescope
needs to send data back to Earth this is
where the telescope could potentially
benefit from other lunar missions when
the Apollo Astronauts ventured to The
Far Side of the Moon they could not
communicate with Earth the situation has
improved marginally since China launched
the first and only communication relay
satellite for The Far Side of the Moon
in 2018 which is parked in the Earth
Moon L2 LaGrange point which is
communicating with their lunar lander
which became the first lunar lander to
soft land on The Far Side of the Moon in
2019. NASA and the esa will need their
own communication relays for this
mission to operate both both NASA and
the esa have allocated substantial
resources for lunar exploration in
particular NASA's Artemis program aiming
to send humans to the Moon South Pole is
said to be in full swing in the coming
decade with the increasing number of
lunar missions communication between the
Moon and Earth will become more
accessible and efficient the hydrogen
mapping Mission itself is only scheduled
for one year of operation the team is
confident that they can gather enough
data in that time to piece together the
evolution of the early universe but of
course the massive radio telescope is
capable of much more than just detecting
early hydrogen signals the long radio
wave spectrum is full of other useful
information when radio waves travel
through magnetic fields they are split
and altered and radio telescopes can
pick up on this and detect and quantify
the magnetic fields of exoplanets
potentially identifying exoplanets life
could survive on the team has already
mapped the known exoplanet systems that
reverse the field of view of the
telescope this is an exciting project
with a lot of scientific potential how
could we not get excited by the
potential of a massive telescope being
constructed on the fair Side of the Moon
all projects like this begin at the same
point before anything is manufactured
the entire design will be prototyped in
a computer-aided design system or as we
call it an engineering card before I
started this YouTube channel I spent
days every week designing Parts in CAD
software and I still use it for 3D
printing projects the software I use for
that is on shape onshape is available to
try for free with the link in the
description whether your company wants
to evaluate a more modern CAD system or
you just need a cad system for home
projects onshape is a fantastic option
onshape system runs entirely on the
cloud allowing engineers and designers
to work together at the same time on the
same design across the world this
prevents issues with having multiple
files for the same design a problem I
ran into frequently for parts I designed
as an engineer where sales reps kept
sending out outdated versions of the
design no more frustrating file
management or servers to deal with
onshape also runs in a browser which
means you can use it on virtually any
device or operating system which is
especially useful for on-shapes more
computationally intensive applications
like finite element analysis and product
renderings whether you are a
professional engineer or a hobbyist
designer onshape is a fantastic option
for your card needs and you can sign up
for a free version with the link in the
description